i
am jessica txomin morales and i am a
neuroscientist at
mike's mega brands institute if you use
brain imaging technology called
functional magnetic resonance imaging more
commonly known as mfr to see
which brain regions are activated
we know certain things studying the
brain is a passion  that arose from being the
only child of immigrant parents i
grew up observing how
cultural differences can lead to differences
in behavior
my family is from asunción paraguay
a somewhat strange country in
south america i
produced a neuroscience podcast in
spanish to bring free
and valuable information to  the Hispanic community I know from my
own experience that there are not many
Hispanics in science and
most of the scientific content is
only available in English but I am going to
change that
[Music]
it is called my last neuron
and I conquered with my last neuron
I hope I can inspire  to the next
generation of neuroscientists  Hispanic people
with this project
i